je ne suis pas sûr du
risque pour notre sécurité personnelle
avec la menace d'une peine à perpétuité,
nous pourrions être inquiets et également être
la cible de Pékin,
mais nous encourageons également le monde, la
communauté mondiale
à laisser notre voix être blessée dans le monde
[Musique]
national  l'éducation impose aux étudiants d'
accepter le parti communiste PCC,
nous pensons que cela relie beaucoup de problèmes, c'est la
ruée vers les banques, l'éducation
contrôle la pensée indépendante des
étudiants [Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements] [Musique] [Musique
]
donc
[Musique]
c'est  une
[Musique] très importante
en fait, il est trop tard et il neige maintenant
la protestation continuera. Les
gens de Hong Kong ne s'arrêteront jamais tant que
Hong Kong ne sera pas le lieu de la démocratie
et de la liberté.
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
vous